To calculate the mean of
the average number of tickets,
we drag a Summarize
tool onto the canvas.
We can use one formula to
calculate the average, and
also exclude any missing
values at the same time.
And that is the AVG No Zero function.
We click on the Average Number of
Tickets field in the configuration
panel, select the Add dropdown and
then select the AVG No Zero function.
Next we add an Append Fields
tool onto the canvas so
we can add the new field we
calculated to every row of data.
Then we connect in all the data and
select Allow All Appends at the bottom.
Now that the mean of the average
number of tickets has been appended to
every record in the dataset,
we can now replace the records
where there is a null value
in the Average Number of Tickets,
with this new calculated field.
To do this we add a Formula tool, and
we're going to update the field
called Average Number of Tickets.
But we're going to
build in an expression,
a conditional expression,
that looks where the value is null,
and replaces it with that new
value that was just calculated.
To do this,
we go to Functions &gt; Conditional,
choose the first IF THEN ELSE condition,
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And build out the condition.
IF IsNull, so we go down to the test
functions, and we're looking for
where the field Average Number
of Tickets is null.
THEN, t becomes the field
that we just calculated.
ELSE, we keep original value of
the Average Number of Tickets.
When we run the workflow, we can verify
that our formula worked properly.
So let's look at the results.
So now there are no longer any null
values here, and you can see the value
that it took was the value of the mean
number of Average Number of Tickets.
Finally, we can add a scatter
plot tool and look at the output.
You configure it the same way
it was configured before, and
now we can compare the scatter
plot to the original.
On the left,
we're looking at the original
scatter plot with all of the data.
And on the right,
we're looking at the scatter plot with
the data plus the imputed values.
So with a quick glance,
we can see that using imputation,
we obtain a slope of the line that
is very close to the original,
providing us with a level of confidence
that this might be the right way
to handle the rows that are missing
the Average Number of Tickets field.